Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott revealed
the name of their baby girl how Kylie
was able to keep her pregnancy top
secret plus we're inside the America's
Got Talent
La auditions hello friends this is the
daily Deni I'm Denny it's been a while
since I've said that so if you're new to
our show
welcome and you came on a good day
because we have a name for the Kylie
Jenner baby
Kylie shared this sweet photo of her
baby girl holding on to her thumb
the little ones named stormy with an eye
no word on the origin of the name just
yet but I have my thoughts alright so
the name is stormy what do we think I
for one have a lot of questions but one
thing is certain
with the arrival of Kylie's new baby
girl there are a lot of Kardashian
Jenner's to keep up with these days even
for Grandma Kris Jenner as et's Kelty
knight found out so we're welding it's a
lot of little people so I love it though
I loved every second of it it's such a
blessing you tell me because I know
you're behind it how do you mastermind
keeping something like Kylie's pregnancy
you know what I'll let Kylie answer that
okay that's her department and she did
it her way and I'm just really proud of
her
life is really good right now and it's
all about the kids and the family and
just keeping everybody happy and healthy
oh is Kris Jenner as a grandmama hi I'm
a spoiler I think I'm doing yeah I'm
getting an A right now I've decided I'm
doing great okay so here's the thing
ét first learned Kylie and boyfriend
Travis Scott were expecting their first
child back in September but Kylie stayed
very low-key up until Sunday when she
announced she gave birth to a girl on
February 1st
that announcement came with a sweet
video documenting the pregnancy a source
told us Kylie wanted to document the
pregnancy and her journey her own way in
privacy even gave fans a first glimpse
at Kim and Kanye's newborn daughter
Chicago West
did you figure out the name I think
we're going to go to Chicago but I asked
you
by switching gears now the search for
the next winner of America's Got Talent
is underway I crashed the open call
auditions in Los Angeles to scope out
the competition hey what's up you guys
Denny here I'm taking you inside the
America's Got Talent
audition I'll try and find the next
million-dollar act are they in this rule
I'm trying to figure out what your act
is based on the costumes you gotta help
me out some addition and magic so what's
your act are you can I see a little oh
my god how do you do that I hear you
guys only have 90 seconds to make an
impression I mean how are you gonna own
those 90 seconds I'm not giving that
time to anybody else I'm not thinking
about anybody else I'm here to do a job
and win this money I drove down from
Morgan I took a leave of absence I've
been on the road for like 10 days in my
van this is my van
we both traveled really far because I'm
from El Paso and took like a 19 hour bus
right here that is what we call
dedication well what's your name and
what's your app my name is Izzy and I'm
playing the ukulele along with singing
so you must be a big fan of grace van
der Waal then yeah yeah pretty big
seeing her it made me think that I could
definitely win as well so what are you
playing for them today I'm gonna play an
original or I actually wrote it with a
friend
it's called emotions can I get a little
taste of it right now yeah sure
[Music]
Wow
are you kidding me the crowds going nuts
she'll take tips what is your act I
usually sing but it's actually a rap so
I'm doing something that's out of my
element but I'm trying it scene I'm
literally trying to orders today I have
I did not come prepared I'm trying to
get on America's Got Talent
you got to teach me your talent all
right show me your moves all right I
think I got it I think I got it don't
tell me and we're gonna do it okay ready
[Music]
[Applause]
signing you see me Simon on the next
million-dollar act don't you think yeah
clearly I think I'm Bruno Mars but don't
worry guys I will stick to my day job
all right but if you have what it takes
there's one more open call to audition
for America's Got Talent season 13 in
Phoenix Arizona on February 24th but you
can also submit a video of your own at
America's Got Talent auditions dot-com
I'm gonna keep practicing my moves
maybe there's next year you never know I
be sure to like it share this video and
I'll see you guys tomorrow
you